notre invité politique ce matin c'est
luc carvounas bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous est même
d'alfortville c'est dans le val de marne
vous êtes porte parole du parti
socialiste et vous êtes président de
l'unca c'est l'union nationale des
centres communaux d'action sociale merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en détention
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par christelle
bertrand du groupe la dépêche bonjour
questel bonjour ryan bonjour le carbone
bonjour on va commencer en parlant de
climat d'écologie d'environnement le
carvounas et cette annonce hier d'anne
hidalgo qui a donc décidé de rendre
payant le stationnement des deux roues
dans la capitale à partir de 2022 seuls
les scooters électriques seront exemptés
de payer ses intérêts ce qui égale 2 2 à
3 euros par an selon les arrondissements
ce qui n'est pas sans conséquences
notamment pour les habitants des
départements limitrophes puisque les
parisiens ont un tarif présidentielle
résidentiel mais les habitants des
départements limitrophes
il risque de payer et en payer le prix
fort est-ce que vous approuvez sept
majeur bacrot le stationnement payant
d'une manière générale c'est remettre
aussi un peu d'ordre du stationnement
moi je les ai vus dans ma commune où le
stationnement n'était pas payant du
moment où j'ai commencé et on la ville
sera entièrement sa seulement payant
d'ici la fin du mandat ou à installer le
stationnement payant bas on a vu des
places se libérer on a vu les choses
s'organisent et sur l'effet spatiale
vous savez le val de marne moi je suis
maire d'alfortville vous l'avez rappelé
le val d'hérens nous sommes le
département où pour la première fois en
france les villes de vincennes et de
charenton ont mis en place le
stationnement payant pour les deux roues
et savez faire un tollé général
et aujourd'hui tout le monde a compris
que ça fonctionnait plutôt pas mal dans
ces communes moi même j'ai demandé à mes
services qu'on étudie cette question du
stationnement payant aussi pour les deux
roues c'est pas pour pénaliser qui que
ce soit c'est encore une fois pour murs
organisé on voit bien sur les mobilités
douces aujourd'hui vous avez les
trottinettes sur les trottoirs les
scooters électriques accessibles
gratuitement
on a mille façons de se déplacer
aujourd'hui
en ile-de-france et en france en général
et moi je pense que c'est une mesure qui
mérite d'être étudiée mais pas sur tout
l'aspect but c'est une contrainte
rendement de payer plus c'est pas ça le
sujet c'est encore une fois quand on est
maire quand on met le stationnement
payant c'est pour organiser justement le
partage de l'espace public
est ce que vous craignez pas une bronca
tidji les jours non parce que c'est des
cons qu'ils s'agit de taxer en moyens
transports c'est compliqué aujourd'hui
les associations de motards notamment
montent au créneau en outre la
performance très lobbyistes mais ils
disent voilà on est on est juste là pour
payer
moi je vous dis tout le temps et je
pense qu'il faut pas balayer comme ça
une proposition sur un sujet aussi
particulier que le stationnement payant
des deux roues sauf les scooters
électriques vous l'avez rappelé on peut
aussi passer par une phase
d'expérimentation de voir comment cela
fonctionne comme est ce que est ce que
c'est vraiment utile
donc faut regarder les choses avec
intérêt et encore une fois c'est le
partage et l'égalité c'est ce que vous
dites matin vont espaces publics y en
avoir des habitants de vaudeville qui
viennent travailler à paris en 2 roues
vous leur dites mais il faut faire cet
effort les voitures paye bien le
stationnement pourquoi les deux rounds
le père est peint en fait c'est le mode
une moto ou un scooter c'est un mode de
déplacement
bompas lardons encore une fois faut pas
être sectaire vous regardez faut poser
les choses selon les experts est monté
et après on tire avec les usagers et les
bénéficiaires les conséquences par
l'environnement et la loi au sénat a
commencé à étudier la loi qui m'a lundi
les écologistes trouve que ce texte est
insuffisant caisse compte en pensez vous
alors je vais être très honnête avec
vous je n'ai pas vraiment regardé ce
qu'il y avait donc dans le texte entend
comme beaucoup de monde ce qu'il en est
après je trouve quand même que ce
gouvernement
n'a pas dans son adn emmanuel macron n'a
pas dans son adn l'écologie on nous a
fait on nous a amusé on amuse la galerie
avec l'action citoyenne qui a formulé
des propositions le président est venu
leur dire il y aura même un référendum
sur bois puis on n'a rien vu du tout bon
moi je vous le disais tout à l'heure
avant d'entrer sur le plateau c'est
quand même ce gouvernement qui a
supprimé le fret le transport
ferroviaire pour favoriser plus de poids
lourds sur les routes donc des mesures
dans ce texte des mesures écologiques
certaines ont certainement alors après
que les écolos au cri'art ou c'est pas
suffisant ils font dans leur job et
c'est normal et je les soutiens
après je si j'avais eu le temps de
d'examiner le texte aurait pu vous en
parler un peu plus et je suis plus
parlementaire une mesure qui qui fait
parler quand même la convention
citoyenne souhaitait interdire les vols
quand on peut relier une ville et à une
autre en moins de 2h30
les sénateurs veulent rétablir cette
mesure qu'est ce que vous en pensez
quand on entend dire quand on a interdit
quelque chose faut toujours proposer
autre chose
moi je veux bien je vais souvent en
corrèze dans ma belle famille c'est un
trajet de cinq heures en voiture autant
en train donc
donc à un moment donné moi je veux bien
qu'on interdise les vols intérieurs mais
au profit de quoi a priori du train oui
donc vous voyez vous voyez un réseau
ferroviaire développer à un moment où
les lignes secondaires vont être
rapatriés ou en compétences régionales
vous voyez nos collectivités
territoriales avoir suffisamment de
moyens aujourd'hui avec des budgets
exponentielle pour développer encore
plus de moyens de transport un moment
donné c'est aussi à l'état c'est à
l'état l'état stratège de mettre en
oeuvre les modes de déplacements de nos
concitoyens il suffit pas d'interdire
pour interdire c'est de proposer
d'autres modes de transport alternatifs
vestiaire dans le ferroviaire par
exemple bien sûr bien sûr on parler de
la crise sanitaire et de la vaccination
qui depuis
donc aux vins et aux adolescents mais
elle semble marquer un peu le pas cette
vaccination est ce que c'est ce que vous
constatez vont le terrain alors dans la
cage était le 8 janvier dernier le
premier centre de vaccination d'île de
france
au passage 17000 euros d'investissement
40000 euros de frais de fonctionnement
tous les mois porté par les
contribuables alfortvillais pour
vacciner tous les franciliens et pas
d'engagement de l'état et pour le moment
je n'ai pas eu un euro de l'état comme
président de l'association des maires du
mail de mende j'étais avec la préfète du
val de marne au téléphone aspect
d'ailleurs pour lui dire à quel moment
l'état va commencer à nous donner une
compensation
vous êtes le seul dans notre cas où ah
non non non non non mais non je dors
j'en discute avec stéphane beaudet
qu'est le président l'association des
maires d'île de france
on avait fait un conseil
d'administration il ya peu il disait lui
même
finalement c'est pas un cadeau que
d'avoir un centre de vaccination dans sa
commune le fameux quoi qu'il en coûte
affichée par président et leur raison de
le dire des choses ont été faites mais
il n'a pas été seulement porté par
l'état il on a marché sur deux ans dans
cette affaire collectivités et état est
aujourd'hui moi je sens pas de 2,2
ralentissement jeu j'étais encore hier
avec mon directeur de centre de santé
municipal jérôme mazères et on est
aujourd'hui sur un trend de 1300
vaccination par semaine on avait tous
les créneaux sont là avec des créneaux
de libre non il nous reste des doses en
fin de journée donc on essaie de faire
en sorte de ne perdre aucune mais ça
fonctionne et moi j'appelle tous nos
compatriotes qui nous écoutent ce matin
sincèrement il faut aller se faire
vacciner
faut pas croire parce qu'il fait beau
aujourd'hui à faire 35 degrés qu'on peut
marcher dans les rues que les terrasses
sont ouverts à nouveau si on ne continue
pas cette vaccination est là les
collectivités jouent un rôle important
les centres communaux d'action sociale
et les centres de sauter joue un rôle
primordial
alors on n'arrivera pas à la vaincre
cette pandémie et on risque même
d'entrer dans un quatrième confinant les
spécialistes le disent
l'horizon octobre novembre prochain
juste un mot ce que nous avait dit sur
les finances des communes est ce que les
communes qui ont ouvert des centres de
vaccination à vont se retrouver perdante
financièrement c'est ce que vous
craignez aujourd'hui mais forcément
aujourd'hui
soyons clairs une ville comme
alfortville 45000 habitants
l'an dernier quand j'enlève tout ce que
l'état nous a apporté parce que l'état
de
et aussi des subventions cela a coûté
très exactement cinq cent mille euros à
la collectivité en dépenses imprévues
masques etc
aujourd'hui un centre de vaccination
comme le mien c'est un coût de
fonctionnement à 40000 euros par mois
cinq postes temps complet chaque jour
des gens qui ont été pour deux d'entre
eux recruter expressément pour cela et
trois autres à qui je demande de faire
autre chose que le métier pour lequel
j'ai été recruté pour être h24 dans ce
sens de santé et que nous dit le
gouvernement
le ministère de la santé nous dit ah bah
chère mère au pluriel on va pas vous
rembourser ces cinq postes où vous
paiera les heures supplémentaires
mais il ajoute municipaux de façon vous
alliez payer mais on se moque de qui là
on se moque de qui donc aujourd'hui il y
a des effets d'annoncé crient à la
réalité que nous vivons au quotidien
nous les maires c'est qu'on est seul
pour les sols et peut importe mois sur
un sujet comme celui là je ferai aucune
polémique
je dis juste et je tire le cid le signal
d'alarmé à l'état et je profite de votre
antenne de dire penser à nous les
meilleurs parce qu'on est en train de
dépenser beaucoup d'argent
aidez nous mais en même temps tous les
maires que je connais tous les maires
que je connais ne mégote pas en disant
il faut le faire c'est c'est évident
mais c'est de l'argent qui n'investirait
pas ailleurs ah ça c'est clair
aujourd'hui valérie pécresse demande la
fin du couvre feu et la fin de
l'obligation du port du masque en
extérieur qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est ce que c'est le bon moment par mois
je suis pas médecin
j'écoute beaucoup de faits 500 visites
et sorties au plateau certains d'entre
eux disent le couvre-feu aujourd'hui est
ce qui sert vraiment à quelque chose ou
non bon et en même temps les gestes
barrières pour parler comme ça de
manière générale ça participe aussi à
favoriser ce que je disait d'aller se
faire vacciner parce que si on pense que
ça y est c'est fini on pourra rentrer à
une heure du matin je ne porte plus mon
masque non un moment donné c'est ce que
disait quand même au delà
le couvre feu mais être plus
intransigeant sur le respect des gestes
barrières
oui mais aussi vous êtes savez j'ai été
consulté par la préfète du val de marne
sur un décret qui se prépare pour le
gouvernement et le premier ministre a
demandé à chaque préfet de solliciter
les présidents d'associations de mer
pour avoir leur opinion sur le 30 juin
prochain faut-il ou pas levé le port du
masque
moi j'ai donné mon avis l'extérieur
voilà moi j'ai donné mon avis j'ai dit
non je pense que c'est trop tôt je pense
que quand on aura suffisamment de
françaises et de français vaccinés et
qu'on aura des chiffres
aujourd'hui 30 millions premières
vaccinations 15 millions à peu près 2 de
vaccination
quand on aura un volume suffisamment
important là on pourra commencer à
enlever le mas manière symbolique je
sais que c'est difficile ce que je dit
de te dire en plein été on porte le
masque
mais je pense aussi que ça une valeur de
symbole et un moment donné lever tous
les symboles des gestes barrières c'est
pas bon mais ce que vous ne dites c'est
que sur ce sujet de gouvernement
consulte les maires à oui je voulais je
vous le confirme
la préfète du val de marne m'a appelé
sur instruction du premier ministre qui
demande à tous les préfets de consulter
les présidents d'associations de mer
pour avoir leur avis sur un décret qu'il
prépare pour le 30 juin prochain en
toutes langues
l'ambiance mans on entend aujourd'hui je
vous confiance le gouvernement je pense
se prépare à faire
à dire aux français vous pouvez ne plus
porter le masque à compter du 1er
juillet à l'extérieur c'est la première
fois que vous êtes consulté comme ça
elle a été régulièrement durant la crise
non non on a été consultée régulièrement
pas forcément on a été consulté je veux
pas être dira le contraire
après une fois le premier on dire que la
décision était très parisienne venait de
l'elysée que les élus locaux ont été peu
je verrai alors j'ai découvert au
premier confinement le préfet de
l'époque m'a appelé pour me dire ce qui
allait se passer
les confinements qui ont suivi je
découvrais les choses en écoutant
premier ministre à la télé on va parler
d'un autre sujet sujets de société c'est
la fin j alain cocq et militant d'une
fin de vie digne est décédé hier par
suicide assisté en suisse dans un
dernier message il a fustigé le manque
de courage de la classe politique est ce
qu il a raison pas d'avoir si monsieur a
beaucoup de courage déjà pensé à l'acte
la fois sa fin de vie à lui ce qu'il a
fait et la manière dont il le fait pour
aider
finalement c'est il ya une grande
hypocrisie change parlais tout à l'heure
moi le premier comme mon père âgé de 83
ans était en fin de vie
les médecins ont demandé à mes deux
frères ma soeur et à moi même de nous
rencontrer pour nous demander que
fait-on si jamais l'état de santé
périclite et l'on comprend quoi on
comprend qu'on nous demande finalement
d'accepter une forme d'accompagnement de
faim dit et c'est ce qui s'est passé
donc tu tous les manières toutes les
familles qui m'écoutent aujourd'hui et
ce matin on l'a tous vécu ça pousse tous
sauf qu'on est seul donc à un moment
donné c'est aussi aux législateurs aux
responsables politiques de poser le
débat pourquoi on peut faire une fin de
vie ailleurs qu'en france pourquoi
d'autres pays ont eu sept courage de
porter des questions que je comprends
extrêmement sensible en jeu et ça j'en
suis persuadé mais en même temps mais
pourquoi ce débat est si compliqué en
france aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya une
forme de tabou sur la question
voilà mais on sent bien que d'année en
année le tabou commence à se lever mais
aujourd'hui parce que ça ne fait pas
plaisir à certains
au corps électoraux donc on veut pas en
parler c'est ça qui sont du courage
quand le précédent demande à françois
hollande a porté le mariage pour tous il
fallait du courage région c'est quelque
chose donc un moment donné c'est elle
n'a pas porté cette question de la fin
de vie il n'en a pas eu le temps tous
les corps mais c'était pas pour autant
qu'on l'avait pas abordé et que les
socialistes on en a jamais parlé mais je
pense que ça doit être ça doit faire la
concorde c'est pas un sujet partisans
c'est un sujet qui doit nous rassembler
pour voir de quelle manière on peut
accompagner des gens qui souffrent voilà
qui sont dans des maladies incurables
qui souffre le martyre qu'est ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui le consensus n'est pas
réunies pour tous les cas je pense que
cela pourra faire partie du débat de
l'élection présidentielle
anciennement autres sujets de société
c'est la pma pour toutes
qui est examinée en ce moment au
parlement le sénat la rejettera a priori
la semaine prochaine mais tenez la sas à
l'assemblée nationale est-ce que là
aussi sur ce sujet emmanuel macron il
n'a pas fait ce que le parti socialiste
n'a jamais fait je suis une promesse des
mails macron dans son projet
présidentiel
il le met en place très bien je il avait
le mandat de cinq ans pour le faire je
peux dire c'est enfin matin il l'a dit
il le fait et j'en que c'est bien mais
il faudra avoir le courage de d'avoir
tous les débats et j'ai vu colis rien
il compose sur la gpa et j'ai vu que
olivier verrons a commencé à énoncer
qu'on pouvait avoir ce débat là aussi
dans les temps avait déjà très bien
ayons tous les débats allez me dire que
vous vous êtes favorable à aller plus
loin et à vous êtes fameux oui bien sûr
bien sûr et ça veut dire qu'après la pma
pour tout il faut tout de suite on
passer au débat sur l'âge et il faut
avoir un débat apaisé et arrêter de dire
que c'est juste la marchandisation du
ventre d'une femme ce n'est pas vrai
parce que l'ap erik les percées un
premier personne et à ses sous toutes
les personnes qui ont fait une gpa à
l'étranger
on vous explique le processus c'est tout
sauf de la marchandisation voilà est
donc un moment donné et d'ailleurs
toutes les statistiques le démontrent et
et il chausse invite à regarder ce que
je vous dis tous les enfants nés d'une
gpa peut vivre très bien voilà il n'y a
pas de sujet ils sont très heureux dans
leur famille et 7 pma pour tout c'est un
premier pas vers un gp a donc passé un
premier pas on va parler des régionales
christ est alors un peu politique les
élections régionales pour le parti
socialiste
s'annonce pas mal mais pas forcément
très bien dans certains endroits de
plusieurs régions sont menacées
notamment la bretagne le centre val de
loire
est ce que c'est un peu la fin des
bastions du parti socialiste au niveau
régional jantes alors les élections
récentes ont démontré que la notion de
bastions n'existe plus depuis longtemps
donc moi je sais pas ce que c'est un
bastion alors par contre je sais ce que
c'est que d'être en mode de challenger
permanent et je le vis dans ma ville et
parce qu'il fait toujours convaincre pas
croire que les choses sont installés a
dit à mme aeternam je pense pas que le
parti socialiste sortira affaibli de
cette séquence je pense que c'est garder
toutes vos régions bah je l'espère et on
fait tout pour
et je pense que il y aura une prime au
sortant qu'ils soient de gauche ou de
droite on l'a vécu avec les municipales
et que nos concitoyens partout il vit ce
fonds rendu compte et sa difficulté
désormais de l'utilité d'une région
forte d'un département fort d'une file
forte parce qu on a passé notre temps
dans notre carrière h à chaque fois
expliqué voilà les compétences d'une
ville d'un département d'une région du
pilat crise sanitaire
nos concitoyens pensent que nous sommes
les couteaux suisses de tous et qu'on
peut tout faire et là ça pose un petit
problème parce que c'est pas vrai donc
pour ce qui est des régionales à
commencer par l'île de france où je vois
la belle campagne de mon amie audrey
pulvar qui est un meeting ce soir à japy
on va un petit peu chaud mais ça fera
l'ambiance
justement je ressens la gauche est très
divisée en ile-de-france 1 il ya trois
lys 3 lys qui sont donnés autour de 10 %
dans les sondages entre 10 et 12 % voire
en dessous de la barre des 10% selon les
sondages est ce que vous redoutez
l'élimination non non non je le profond
dans les trois lits soins de suite 10 %
je pense fait bien sûr et je ne crois
pas du tout à cela parce que quand on
regarde il y a nos mémoires 1268 commune
en ile-de-france nombreux entre elles
sont gérées par la gauche qu'à soi
écologistes communistes socialistes
citoyenne ce terrain donc je vois plutôt
que audrey pulvar est la mieux à même au
regard des sondages d'emmener un
rassemblement de la gauche au second
tour de faire le meilleur score voire
même de charger la présidente sortante
donc dimanche prochain les urnes par
l'euro mais je ne suis pas inquiet est
ce qu'à un échec ne serait plus là ce
serait un coup dur
les proches d'anne hidalgo est ce que ce
sera un coup dur pour la candidature
présidentielle d'anne delvaux jeu quel
rapport
quel rapport entre audrey pulvar si le
rapport c'est audrey pulvar et adjointe
au maire de l'albère de paris je vous
confirme elle est adjointe aux gardes de
la maire de paris allait soit menée par
la maire de paris mais elle a été
soutenue par tout le monde à commencer
par moi qu'en octobre dernier
c est apparue ça qu'on est sûrs quasi
naturelle nous avions rassemblé tous les
ténors du parti socialiste autour
d'audrey pulvar dans tous les
départements et nous avons tous choisie
audrey pulvar c'est pas le choix express
d'une personne c'est un choix collectif
alors un débat est ouvert aujourd'hui
dès à présent sur l'attitude à avoir
entre les deux tours il est ouvert j'ai
la république en marche mais chez vous
aussi ce qu'il faut se retirer en cas de
risque
de rassemblement national victoire du
rassemblement national un certain âge
alors retirer sans conditions comme le
souhaitent certains le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
olivier faur provoqua un bureau national
vendredi soir pour que nous puissions
parler collectivement il y aura des
choix à faire politique
quelle est votre position à vous sur le
sujet je suis content le désistement des
derniers régimes moi je pense que c'est
une très mauvaise idée parce que cela
supprime d'abord pour des des électeurs
un choix politique
alors qu'on enlève de l'hémicycle on l'a
vécu en 2014 à fréjus comme mon ami elsa
di méo s'était retirée et pourtant le
maire de fréjus a été élu en 2014 réélu
dès le premier tour en 2020 et après on
a dit elsa di méo ou conseil régional a
été conseiller régional c'est son seul
mandat elle était la voix du parti
socialiste dans cette région paca on lui
a dit battu désiste aussi et du coup
depuis on n'a plus aucune voix éminente
donc on nous demande quoi un moment
donné je vais vous dire le front le
rassemblement national il ce combat sur
les idées ou conditions combat
politiquement et pour ça il faut des
soldats dans les hémicycles pour le
combattre donc à un moment donné
moi je suis très clair mais il s'était
déjà ma position
c'était ma position 2015 j'étais content
le désistement républicain
il en a été décidé autrement on a vu le
résultat en région sud les sondages
disent qu'en cas de triangulaire dont
kantien de m en cas de maintien de la
gauche la victoire est quasi assurée
pour thierry mariani ça veut dire vous
préférez une victoire du rassemblement
national et être présent dans
l'hémicycle
plutôt que
avant - chez le récent d'abord moi ce
que je préfère c'est la victoire de la
gauche un partout où c'est possible ça
c'est mon premier truc et je vais faire
mon possible on va faire hara kiri avant
le premier tour et son résultat
après je vous dis on aura un débat où
sera peut-être pas collectivement
d'accord pour les positions à la fois au
second tour moi ce que je constate juste
c'est que dans les deux régions en gros
où il ya potentiellement un risque de
voir le rassemblement national gagner si
je regarde bien les sondages qui ont été
publiés le 10 thomas républicain sert à
rien c'est ce qui s'est finalement
égaliser ce qui s'est passé à perpignan
ce qui s'est passé à fréjus c'est ce qui
risque de se passer ce passé en paca et
moi je fais partie de ceux qui ne
veulent pas ne pas voir de conseillers
régionaux de gauche dont les missiles
pour combattre et monsieur mariani et
monsieur muselier qui seront eux quoi
qu'il se passe sur ce que vous nous
dites sur un bureau national vendredi
soir c'est à dire avant le premier tour
avant les résultats du premier tour dont
il y aura une position commune au parti
socialiste qui devront s'appliquer à
l'ensemble des candidats y aura pas de
choix région par région
je pense qu'il y aura une position voilà
je collectivités la position collective
ce désistement républicain je suis dans
un parti politique ou une questionner
moelleux carvounas je vous donne ma
position
si le mal est minoritaire mon adn ça
toujours été de respecter la parole de
mon parti je respecterai ce que mon
parti choisira de faire donc ça sera une
position commune annoncé dès lundi
bien sûr à new york dès vendredi soir
rendu public vendredi soir - la torah
dimanche quand même les régions du
premier tour
la question qu est l on compte on dit
pas de désistement sans contrepartie un
désistement avec contreparties en
revanche un district contrepartie c'est
quoi c'est le fameux accords techniques
alors je trouve ça ridicule aussi au
ridicule total passe car là pour le coup
çà çà çà çà on voit un message de bon
ach total de la vie politique je sais
pas ce que ça veut dire de prendre
demain dans une liste qui sera
majoritaire des élus d'opposition ça
c'est ridicule d'accord merci beaucoup
merci du carbone harcèlement était notre
invité ce matin merci beaucoup creissels
bertrand a les résidents ont garé la une
de la dépêche
c'est les bleus à la une de la dépêche
et les bleus à l'euro ça commence fort
après la victoire hier de l'équipe de
france merci beaucoup
[Musique]